did you know that Sirius XM now has a
share channel thoughts today channel 4
yeah you knew that yeah he loved share
yeah I'm going to see her in two weeks
are you gonna go see the show no her you
saw my sort of show the Broadway gonna
see her now he's going to see her you
know she's touring an income yeah she's
doing
Barclays oh yeah in Brooklyn yeah you
got good feet yeah no [ __ ] yeah he's the
head of the sheriff any [ __ ] around
when it comes to fair know last time he
went to when was the last time you saw
cher in Vegas in Vegas and didn't you
like keep track of how many outfit
changes yeah I was like 12 13 out you
know outfit he's a mega fan and they do
the same thing at the cher show you know
they're actors they'd change they're
doing share and that's what Cher okay
alright you're so [ __ ] angry this
morning she's right let me check out
there running this thing on the shared
channel like a promo before your face
the share channel for a limited time
starting noon today on spotlight channel
4 and the Sirius XM app and connected
devices and speakers her heads spend
decades I got you her movies are
timeless
she's here with her own Sirius XM
channel it's so many things watching
your life flashing before your face
the share channel for channel 4 and the
Sirius XM app okay I'm gonna have to
listen emit well you're gonna be here in
Ronnie's car for the next month you
should go back I picture we could work
it so you could go backstage or meet her
what would you say just like high end I
how are you I'm in the Adam Sandler
movie add one would I'm the president of
the cher fan club and Goldberg's friend
and by the way Ronnie does recommend the
Broadway show other shows awesome what
is so good about that it's just the way
they do her life in music and what is
the highlight the highlight is just the
whole thing of her life second cuz
there's three shares yeah for chair
three different shares the young one
isn't the middle one and then there's
the one now